معنا من البنتاجون المتحدث باسم البنتاجون
الجنرال برايدر ضيفنا مرحبا بك
بالنسبه لهذه الضربات هل هنالك تقييييم
ونتيجه لها
واضحه اولا شكرا لاستضافته اليوم وان يقدر
اعطائي هذه الفرصه لاتحدث اليكم ليله امس
ما ناه كان عمليه متعدده الجنسيات شاركت
في الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
بدعم من استراليا والبحرين وكندا
ودوله اخرى ولقيام بعمليات عسكريه ضد
اهداف عسكريه داخل المناطق تسيطر عليها
الحوثيون في اليمن
وذلك ايقاف قدراتهم على القيام بهذه
الهجمات غير القانونيه والمتهور التي
شاهدناها تحصل في المنطقه ما زلنا نقيم
نتائج هذه الضربات المؤشرات الاوليه تدل
على النتائج جيده جدا ولحد الان لم نشاهد
اي اجراءات انتقاميه او رد رد ولكن نتابع
الامر ونحن مستعدون لاتخاذ كل الاجراءات
اللازمه كما هو الضروره في نهايه المطاف
نريد ان نتاكد بان هذه الممرات المائيه
الدوليه تبقى امنه للملاحه البحريه الج
الدوليه ونا سنك على ذلك بالنس بالنسبه
للاعلان عن هذه هي الضربات كيف كان هل
تواصلت مع جهات في المنطقه مع جهات يمنيه
او
اقليميه وحذرت او ابلغت بعض الاطراف قبل
بدء او شن الهجمات
كما تعلمون نحن دائما نتشاور بشكل جيد مع
شركائنا وحلفائنا في المنطقه وخارج
المنطقه وبالتالي مره اخرى نواصل القيام
بذلك في المستقبل الشيء المهم هنا وكما
تعلمون هو ان هذه الهجمات
الحوثيه تؤثر على اكثر من 50 بلدا التي
لديها سفن وبضائع تجاريه تمر عن طريق هذا
الممر المائي الهام وكما تعلمون جيد ويعلم
مشهدكمدي العالميه يمر في هذا من هذا
المكان ورغم التحذيرات كثيره والطلبات
قدمناها للحوثيين للتوقف عن ذلك لم
يتوقفوا لذلك ليله امس اتخذنا الاجراء
المتناسب والملازم وهذا نامل انه يبعث
رساله هامه والاهم ذلك ان نقلل قدره
الحوثيين على القيام بمثل هذه الهجمات او
النشاطات المجلس السياسي للحوثيين يتحدث
عن رد ويتحدث عن استمرار هذه الهجمات على
اي سفينه متوجهه الى اسرائيل هل معنى ذلك
ان مثل هذه الهجمات لن تمنعهم ربما ايضا
لن تؤثر في
قدراتهم في الواقع هذا طبعا هو دعوه هو ما
ي يقوله الحوثييون وامل ان الرساله التي
بعثناه لهم امس كانت رساله واضحه ومره
اخرى اقول ان النقطه الاساسيه هنا ان
الاهداف التي
ضربناها مع مع شركائنا الدوليين كانت
الهدف منها تقليل و تقليل قدراتهم
الصاروخيه
وردتهم السواحل اضافه الى قدراتهم
المسيرات
الانتحاريه وبالتالي وكما ذكرتم انتم هنا
من المهم جدا ان نفهم انهم انهم لم يكن
يستهدفون السفن المتوجه نحو اسرائيل فقط
فغالب السفن التي استهدفت في المنطقه لا
علاقه لها لم يكن ليها اي علاقه بهذا
النزاع الحاصل حاليا في غزه
وبالتالي هذا شكل لنا مشكله دوليه تتطلب
حلا دوليا وليله امس
و بالتعاون مع حلفائنا قمنا بالعمل مره
اخرى لخذ الاجراءات المناسبه وال متناسبه
على اهداف الحوثيين لتقليل قدرتهم على
قيام مثل هذه الهجمات في المستقبل وفقط
للتوضيح نحن نتعامل مع اعلان رسمي من هذه
الجماعه انها تستهدف السفن المتوجهه الى
اسرائيل او مملوكه للاسرائيليين لكن ماذا
لو لم تنجح هذه الخطوات هذه الضربات التي
اسميتها بالتحذيرات
لديكم توضيحكم ولديهم اعلانهم طبعا اكمل
في السؤال ماذا لو لم لم تنجح هذه الضربات
التي اسميت جزء منها رسائل وضربات لتحد من
خطوره وقدرات الحوثيين لو لم تنجح ما هي
الخطوه المقبله ماذا انتم فاعلون
نعم اولا الهدف هنا هو ان نتاكد بان
التجاره الدوليه والسفن الدوليه
وبحريه يمكن ان تمر في هذا المر المائي
الهام بطريقه امنه وسالمه هذا هو الهدف
هذا ما ن الجميع ولا احد يريد ان يشاهد
هجمات
ضد سفن تجاريه بريئه وهذا اذا ما سن نواصل
العمل من اجله لن ادخل في اي افتراضات او
راضيات لكن رئيسنا ووزير الدفاع كان
واضحين جدا باننا سنتخذ المزيد من
الاجراءات اللازمه كما هو مناسب اذا ما
احتجنا ان ندافع عن قواتنا واذا ما احتجنا
للدفاع عن التجاره الدوليه والملاحه
البريه وحمايه السفن هناك اذا مره اخرى
نامل ان الحوثيين سيتوقفون عن هذه الهجمات
المتهوره واننا سنحافظ على وجودنا المون
مع شركائنا في المنطقه للتاكد من ان
التجاره الدوليه والسفن الدوليه وحياه
البحار بامان وسلام سياسيا الان ماذا عن
الدول التي رفضت المشاركه سواء في هذه
الضربات او الدول التي ادانت قصف اليمن
الا تشعر الولايات المتحده انها تخلق
واقعا جديدا
ومشكله اكبر من من اليمن وا اضطرابا في
الاقليم اولا اعتقد اننا كلنا نستطيع ان
نتفق بان المشكله كانت مشكله خلقها
الحوثيون عندما قاموا
ب حوالي 27 هجوما على السف على خطوط
السلاح الج الدوليه بداء من شهر سبتمبر
وبعد تحذيرات عديده وبعد دعوات كثيره لهم
لتوقف عن هذا التصرف المتهور ولكن وصدر
تصريح من قبل 14 دوله في ذائد الولايات
المتحده بدايه يناير بان نحذرهم بان سيكون
هناك نتائج وتبعات لكن الحوثيون تجاهلوا
هذا التحذير اذا هم الذي خلقوا المشكله هم
الذين خلقوا الوضع الخطر والولايات
المتحده تعاون مع المجتمع الدولي لانهاء
هذه المشكله طبعا هناك هذا امر مختلف
تماما هناك امر مخت عن ضرات ليله امسه
هناك جهود جهود اخرى او تسمى جود
حمايه الازدهار وهذه عمليه مستقله تعمل
سويه في تحالف دفاعي لحمايه ملاحه البحر
الاحمر والسفن هناك هذه العمليه سوف تستمر
وهي منفصله تماما عن ما حصل لله امس فهذا
تحالف دفاعي فقط وهو فيه اكثر من 20 دوله
بعضها من دول المنطقه اذا مره اخرى الهدف
النهائي هو هو استعاده وعاده السلام
والاستقرار في البحر الاحمر وانا ندعو
الحوثيين ان يكونوا من يتحلوا بالمسؤوليه
هنا وان يتوقفوا عن هذه الهجمات غير
القانونيه والمتهور شكرا لك الجنرال
برايدر المتحدث باسم البنتاجون شكرا جزيلا
لك